la petite bombe
puisque d'écran ou fort plus que d'avoir
des super pouvoirs parce que j'ai
toujours voulu faire partie d'une bande
samia moi on va [ __ ] le faire les
injures bon il faut quelqu'un qui ait
pas de copains du tout que personne
super vite abandonnée dans votre banque
comme ça d'un coup meilleur des mondes
moscou
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce que vous voulez en frites
l'écologie tu en penses quoi
à la pollution de la rivière les
poissons tout ça je les aime si j'aime
les poissons ouais les truites et voilà
c'est comme ça je suis entré dans la
bande
une bande qui allait faire un truc de
taille
[Musique]
montpellier 6 attaché comme ça mais une
fois au but jaloux je sais pas moi
s'accorde aux oscars pour ma libération
c'est le montant qui les rend fous
trouver des copains chantier en faillite
est vrai les enfants qu'est ce que vous
allez le faire
désolé c'est hissera au maire
pour le relâcher faut arrêter tout ça on
peut pas le garder
les brebis le brebis tu les aimes le
gourbi les tubes attrait pour une brebis
ouais une chèvre